hey everyone it's sarah gesture nurse RN
calm and in this video i'm going to be
going over how to check vital signs what
we're going to be doing is checking the
six vital signs which are pain oxygen
saturation temperature heart rate
respirations and blood pressure and
before you start what you want to do is
you want to perform hand hygiene and you
want to provide privacy to the patient
and tell them once you're going to be
doing because you're going to have to
touch them in order to do this so let's
get started the very first thing we want
to do is we want to ask them if they are
in pain so whenever you do that you're
going to have them rated on a scale of
zero to ten with zero being no pain at
all in ten being the worst pain they've
ever had and if they do have pain ask
them the quality what does it feel like
and where it is at
so hi Ben my name is Sarah and I am your
nurse and I'm going to be getting your
vital signs and I perform hand hygiene
and very first thing I want to do is I
want to ask you what your pain rating is
are you having any pain right on the
scale of zero to ten yes
pain in my shoulder and it's a three
okay and what does it feel like it's
just a sharp pain when I raise more okay
so you're having a pain of three and
it's in your left arm and it's sharp
okay now I'm going to get your
temperature there are several ways you
can take a temperature every facility
has a different system set up so use
what they have but you can take it
orally you can take it axillary you can
take it tympanic see in the ear or you
can take it temporally or rectally
rectally is the preferred route usually
on your pediatric patients but in adult
patients normally we do it orally
some things to keep in mind though
axillary and temporally the readings are
going to run about one degree lower than
oral and for tympanic and rectal
temperatures it's going to usually run
about one degree higher than your oral
reading so we are going to check this
orally and what we're going to do turn
your thermometer on make sure you're
using the proper and sleeves if you have
any sleeves for it clean it everything
like that follow your Hospital protocols
and how the patient lifts up their
tongue and
the probe underneath the tongue and have
them close the mouth with the tongue
over the probe and hold it there until
it beeps a normal temperature is about
97 degrees Fahrenheit to 99 degrees
Fahrenheit okay and take the thermometer
Al and Rita and his temperature is 98
point two and then clean it properly per
hospital protocol now I'm going to take
his oxygen saturation every system has
different ways of how they measure it
and different devices this is a little
portable device and what you do is you
put this on the nail bed of the finger
has some red lights in there and those
red lights read through the nail bed the
oxygen saturation a normal oxygen
saturation Oh 2sat as you may hear in
the hospital setting is ninety five
percent to a hundred percent so let's
see what his is put this on the index
finger of the nail bed and then just
look for the reading okay here you can
see that his oxygen saturation is 98%
that is the reading on the top it's read
as spo2
and then on the bottom you will see his
heart rate which is 64 but here in a
second I'm going to show you how to
actually count the heart rate using the
radial artery okay now we are going to
count the heart rate and respiration
generally I like to do this together and
while I'm counting the heart rate I
count that for thirty seconds if it's
regular and in the next thirty seconds I
count the respirations which I look at
the rise and the fall of the chest and
that equals one breath and generally if
you tell a patient you're going to count
their respirations they change their
rate of breathing so it's good to
conglomerate those two together so you
can get a more accurate reading so what
we're going to do is we're going to
first count the heart rate and to do
that you can use several different sites
typically people use the radial which is
right here right below the where the
radius phone is and the groove right
there or you can use the brachial artery
which is in the bend of the arm where
the antecubital fossa areas or you can
use the carotid but here we're going to
use the radial so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to use my - I'm going to
use my index finger and my middle finger
don't use your thumb because you can
a pulse in your thumb so use those two
fingers and just put it over in the
groove of where the styloid processes
and the radial artery and fill that and
count for 30 seconds if it's regular if
it's irregular count for one minute and
a normal pulse rate and an adult is 60
to 100 beats per minute
you
you
okay the heart rate I got 60 and his
respirations were 16 now we are going to
get his blood pressure now whenever
you're getting a blood pressure you want
to make sure that you get the right
sized cup in most settings they have the
automatic blood pressure cuffs where you
don't have to blow it up yourself so
you're really blessed with that but a
lot of times you may have to learn how
to do a manual one now in my previous
video and a card should be popping up I
go over the two-step method if that's
how you're being instructed but in this
video we're going to go over the
one-step blood pressure up how to obtain
it manually so what we're going to do we
are going to palpate the brachial artery
this is in the bend of the arm and make
sure you ask the patient which arm you
can take their blood pressure in because
you don't want to take it in arms with
if they've had blood clots or they have
AV shunts things like that so you want
to make sure you have the right arm and
what you're going to do is you're just
going to have them extend the arm out
and you're going to palpate the brachial
artery this is found in the antecubital
fossa area and have bend the arm towards
this area and extending the arm out
helps that pulse really pop out at you
and just feel that and we feel about
right here because what you're going to
do on your blood pressure cuff you have
these little arrows and it says left arm
right arm and this is his left arm so
we're going to make sure that we put
this arrow about one to two inches above
that artery so let's slide it up and
then make sure our cut it properly so
we're putting that arrow about one to
two inches above where I felt the
brachial artery and we're going to just
put this on here snugly and to make sure
you have the right blood pressure cuff
take about two fingers and slide it
underneath the cuff and make sure it
fits snugly not too tight not too loose
because if you don't fit it correctly
you could get interact inaccurate blood
pressures okay so we have that there and
put your little spigot momen ometer
somewhere where you can see it because
that is where you're going to be finding
your blood pressure so I put our set the
scope in arrears and you're going to use
the diaphragm of your set the scope and
you're just going to place it over where
you have heard that brachial artery and
then you're going to blow the cuff up to
about 182
200 millimeters of mercury or until you
don't hear that brachial artery anymore
okay we're blowing it up to about 200
millimeters of mercury okay over there
and now we're going to let the needle
draw up about 2 to 3 millimeters of
mercury slowly not too fast not too slow
and we're listening for that first sound
and that first and Sam will be our top
number of our blood pressure which is
our systolic so I haven't heard it yet
and I'll let you know whenever I hear it
I hurt it at about the 1:14 mark now
we're listening for whenever it stops
and whenever it stops that's our
diastolic okay it stopped right at 65 so
his blood pressure is 114 over 65 so
that is how you check bottle signs now
whatever you're done remember to let the
patient know what their bottle songs
were and do hand hygiene and clean your
equipment before you go to the next
patient so be sure to check out all my
other videos on nursing skills and thank
you so much for watching